well I hope you've got some time to free
up on your calendar so something was
said recently about the Marvel shows
that are gonna be on Disney Plus and
more specifically about how they're
going to tie into the main MCU films
so we already knew that there was going
to be a much more explicit connection
just by virtue of who was getting shows
I mean the character of Wanda is getting
a show she's from the films Loki's
getting a show the Winter Soldier and
Captain America are getting a show and
there was even speculation that made
sense to me that with the case of some
of these characters as I would think
especially Winter Soldier and Falcon
that it would cover whatever sort of
journey there is for them to have
between where we last left them off and
where you see them at the start of the
next film now my presumption had been
that it would be a filling in of a gap
if you felt that gap needed filling in
but that whatever film they appear in
next will still more or less function on
its own
however some comments from Kevin Feige
recently have indicated instead that if
you don't follow the Disney Plus shows
you're not really gonna have a full
sense of what's going on and that
expands beyond the characters who are
already established in the MCU it is
being said that the characters being
introduced in Disney Plus shows such as
she-hulk Moon Knight possibly possibly
Hamilton will show up in the films and
have significant roles but that they
won't really be explained meaning you
won't know who they are what their deal
is
unless you've been watching the Disney
Plus shows now I'm gonna get a whole lot
of people annoyed with me over this
but this is a bad idea
Annie look here's the thing I understand
this is what a lot of fans want I'm not
even gonna say that I wouldn't enjoy
this to some degree but as a business
plan if that if they actually stick to
what is being implied because let's put
that Asterix on it right now because
they had said ages of shield was gonna
tie into the movies and it never really
did except for some ripple effects from
the movies filtering down in like the
first season so they kind of perjured
themselves on that and that may turn out
to be the case here there again there's
obviously gonna be more connection but
assuming that we can take them at their
word that the movies are going to start
basically not making sense unless you
unless you are also watching the Disney
Plus shows this is not a good idea and
the thing I need to say that geeks don't
like to hear the hardcore fanbase is not
large enough to sustain these things in
and of themselves they need main stream
appeal and I'm sorry there is a very
large number of people who are fans of
the MCU but who don't want to dig in to
a Disney Plus show or who don't read the
comics or have never watched the
cartoons of the x-men growing up or
whatever and that is a bigger percentage
of the movie-going audience that has
made this the franchise that has yielded
the single biggest money-making film of
all time that isn't because of the
hardcore fans that's because of the
mainstream and this move if they do it
the way it's being implied which again I
am kind of skeptical of I think they
might be over
because again the idea appeals to geeks
a lot but if they do it I think they're
kneecapping themselves because if you
actually look at the MCU it's really
only the Avengers films that don't make
sense if you haven't been following
everything else the individual films for
the most part have tracked and made
sense within their own series now
granted if you're going to watch Captain
America the Winter Soldier it would have
helped to have seen Captain America
First Avenger but that's direct sequel
so you could watch all the Thor movies
and well you may scratch your head
slightly at Doctor Strange you can
figure out what his deal is more or less
from the context in which he appears in
Thor Ragnarok you can figure that out
well enough to move forward ditto
Hulk but we've saved the Avengers if you
haven't been following all the other
stuff well especially by endgame and
also infinity war I would argue they
don't really make sense now there are
people who are gonna say but those are
the biggest money makers of all
obviously this works and like yeah it
worked as a I'm sorry to say it as a
novelty as a everyone wanted to see if
this actually would come together we've
now seen it it's had its proof of
concept you're going to get diminishing
returns if you keep trying to do that
the real strength of the MCU has been
and this is kind of the secret string
because they're designed so that you
feel like you have to watch everything
to know what's going on but honestly
most of these seep franchises standalone
and Wow maybe not 100% of everything is
explained if you only
watch any single given series everything
does at least make sense because the
things brought in from other series are
either in a small capacity or make sense
in context regardless of whether you
know the specific instances that happen
in other franchises now that's the
balancing act I've already been doing
with the movies Disney Plus first off is
going to be huge let us acknowledge that
how ever the numbers as we tend to get
them as far as what streaming services
tend to do more people go to the movies
then stream any given show by and large
streaming numbers you are generally
comparable to television numbers before
you know before streaming really started
to eating into them so and and that's
the other thing it changes what the MCU
is to people because the MCU at this
point for people who aren't pre-existing
like weren't fans of the characters
before the movie started happening to
them it is a fun time to go to the
theater but that doesn't mean that
they're gonna want to sit at home and
stream for the thing that they like
going to the theater to see and I think
they run the risk of audiences being
frustrated or resentful if they start
getting the feeling that you that you
are forcing me to watch all this other
stuff to even understand the things I
like at a certain point unless you are
all in which again some people are and
for them this is Christmas but if that's
not you and that will put you in the
minority at a certain point this becomes
homework and you keep pushing it and it
becomes
well I'm gonna find something else to do
with my time because I'm literally
sinking hours of my week to watch these
streaming shows just so that I can
understand the movies that I actually
care about and maybe in some instances
people who watch the streaming shows go
oh now I care about this but there's
still gonna be a significant number of
them who are gonna be like I feel like I
have to watch this and if they feel like
they have to watch it and it doesn't
hook them in which that's part of the
gamble here they're gambling that these
things are gonna be good enough to hook
people in and if they are really good on
the streaming services then that is sort
of the main escape hatch they have for
the problem I'm laying out here if these
series are exceptional pretty much
across the board that's going to pretty
much mitigate what I'm talking about but
if they are average if they aren't well
god they're bad but even if they're just
good it still is going to start to feel
like work it's going to feel like an
obligation and nobody likes being
assigned an obligation at a certain
point you go am I actually getting
enjoyment equal through the amount of
time I'm sinking into this thing and if
you have to watch a 10-hour series in
order to enjoy a two-hour movie you push
that too hard and people are gonna start
going the the this equation doesn't
balance and they'll bail not on mass not
in a wave but you're gonna see
diminishing returns thing over thing
over thing so again I am skeptical that
they're actually going to tie things as
explicitly as seems to be getting
implied but I think I'm doing it was a
bad idea
financially and long-term creatively is
it a good idea maybe depends on the
outcome I suppose but I think if you
want the MCU to continue for as long as
possible
this proposal it's it's putting too many
eggs in one basket
it is tying something that is already
successful and then tying it to
something that you hope will be
successful but if it isn't or isn't as
successful as the thing that's already
working then it's just going to drag it
down well see Disney Plus launches soon
I don't know when the first streaming
show for thats Marvel related goes live
but yeah I wasn't thrilled about that
and I say that as someone who really
loves this stuff but is running out of
hours in the day to take this in and as
much as I like Marvel it's not the only
thing I want to watch and I know that
they think providing me with hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours on
streaming of Marvel plus the movies
basically means I'll watch nothing but
Marvel but I don't want to do that and
structuring the story so it feels like I
have to do that otherwise I'm gonna get
no enjoyment out of it that's that's a
dangerous type of rope tightrope to walk
because I might eventually decide it's
not worth it so what are your thoughts
about the idea of the streaming shows on
Disney Plus being so integrated that the
movies will not completely make sense
unless you've seen them whatever your
thoughts are on that concept drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you can support me on
patreon helps keep this show going helps
me pay my bills and eat additionally
there is the like to subscribe you can
comment all of which are a big help or
you can share this video that's an even
bigger help so there's all this stuff
you can do buttons links but you don't
have to because at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]